now Angelina Jolie and Gwyneth Paltrow
were among the first actresses to speak
out against Weinstein now selma hayek
has new claims for years he was my
monster
that's how Salma describes Weinstein the
actress who starred in several movies
released by Weinstein's production
company credits him with starting her
career but she says there was a dark
side in a New York Times op-ed salma
claims that the movie mogul would turn
up at her door at all hours of the night
hotel after Hotel location after
location Hayek says that her refusal zuv
massages showers and sex enraged him
quote I don't think he hated anything
more than the word no she goes on to say
that as a kind of payback while working
on the movie Frida he insisted she do a
sex scene with full frontal nudity the
51 year old also claims Weinstein
threatened to kill her Weinstein did not
address that claim but his rep fired
back at Hayek in a statement quote mr.
Weinstein does not recall pressuring
Salma to do a gratuitous sex scene and
all of the sexual allegations as
portrayed by Salma are not accurate
actress Jessica Chastain tweeted support
for Salma and at last night's premiere
of Molly's game she told us voices like
hers are needed right now
I hope we're getting to a point where
we're making lasting changes so women
like selma hayek won't have to go
through
what she did